We are sitting down right now with
Warren Buffett, the chairman of of
Berkshire Hathaway, who for the first
time in 60 years has been watching all
of this from the audience instead of
being on stage. And you know, last year
at this time, Warren, you surprised
everyone with the announcement that you
were stepping down as CEO. Fast forward
a year and here we are. What do you
think?
Well, I think it's all working. It's all
working. I
It isn't our ideal
uh
surrounding area
uh or or environment, I should say,
in terms of deploying cash for
Berkshire.
Uh
but
in terms of how
uh we got the right management. We got
the right arrangement and uh
you know, we can pick our spots and and
and uh
nobody can tell us what to do exactly
and
and uh
so sometimes we're doing nothing, but
other other times we get quite active. I
mean You know, a G spent some time on
the stage today talking about how one of
his keys is to do nothing when it comes
to insurance, when it comes to writing
insurance, which is the same thing that
you have always talked about with
whether to invest or not.
>> Yeah. The world is full of people that
are offering you things to do.
And then the
question is to find find one that, you
know, makes sense.
And there may be 20,000 that make sense
that you don't understand and you just
leave them alone.
You You said that the world or the
surrounding environment is not ideal and
I guess that points to the idea that
there's almost $400 billion
in cash on hand. Although Greg took some
pains to show it it's really more like
$380 billion in cash on hand. [laughter]
But that there's a lot of cash on hand
and you're still active in managing the
portfolio too and looking at stocks.
You're looking around and you don't see
a lot that you want to invest in.
>> No. [clears throat]
Well
then we don't do anything. I mean, we've
better than of the 60 years I've been in
the business,
you know, there's probably
five of them been really juicy. You
know, [laughter]
and uh
I think it was Tom Watson senior at IBM
that uh
said
they asked him the reason why IBM had
been so successful or something like
that. And he said, "I'm smart at spots
and I stay around those spots."
And that's that's the whole thing. And
IBM was in three different businesses
including time clocks and a couple of
and two of the three turned out to be no
good, but
>> [laughter]
>> so they just focused on the one.
What what is it when you look around
that it's just prices are too high at
this point? I I would imagine there are
Greg said this from the stage too. There
are businesses that you like just not at
these prices.
>> I would say I understand
fewer of the businesses as a percentage
of the whole
than I did 10 years ago. I have not
learned
uh
new industries
for some years, you know, and and so I
don't kid myself on that. I'm I'm not
going to learn I'm not going to have an
edge on you know, a whole bunch of uh
younger people that have actually grown
up with them, used the product, seen
things uh
but
it uh
well
as I mentioned, you know, you don't have
to understand too many of them like
Apple.
But looking around, um
let's just get some macro thoughts on
this because I don't know that this is
something that that Greg is going to
comment on per se. Just looking at the
macro stock market environment. What
does this feel like to you? Is does it
feel expensive? Does it feel like there
are opportunities in some places?
>> feels like
you know, I've I've compared it
the market to a one church with a casino
attached. And and people can move
between the church and casino and and
I would say there are more people in the
church and more people in the casino.
But the casino's gotten very attractive
to people. If you're buying one-day
options
or selling them
I mean, that is
uh
that's not investing, it's not
speculating, it's gambling. I mean, just
totally.
There's nobody that can explain why
they're buying an option for one day
unless I may maybe maybe they follow
that that uh
you know, made the $400,000
from knowing when we were going into
Berkshire Hathaway and
doing it. But I mean,
that's pretty and the quantity of those
things is just incredible. So, we've
never had people in a more gambling mood
than now. But that doesn't mean
that investing is terrible. It doesn't
mean that uh
that prices for an awful lot of things
will look very solid. I mean, they you
know, they
had a squeeze and and then and Avis has
some old things. Well, Avis has been
around for 50 years, but
just this past week uh uh and
uh
we have lots more regulation and
everything now, but uh
but people spend their time figuring out
how to get around the rules rather than
follow the rules.
That's just a challenge.
The type of investor you are though is
is you laid it out yourself. In the 60
years you've been doing this in the
business, you've had maybe five juicy
years. I guess that means you're always
looking for the next juicy year. What do
you think it would take to make a juicy
year or a juicy opportunity for you?
It's a phone call in many in some cases.
You know, we
we bought a business last year. It
wasn't
It wasn't big enough to be mean
meanable, we got a letter. Bell Labs?
Yeah, Bell Labs. And
and
uh
you know, and and sometimes there's more
zeros attached to them than others and
and we're big enough to handle anything
and we can make decisions faster and
than anybody and our word is good.
Uh
but uh there's an awful lot of people
that
they're
when they
they're in the business of reselling
something or you know, it's uh
and
it's a lot better if you're a good sales
person
there's no reason to be selling vacuum
cleaners or
you know
as well sell stock, you'll make way more
money.
It's where the money is.
And there's and there's more money
around than ever and uh
you know
But the best opportunities have probably
come when the macro environment
>> That's the most likely, yeah. Well, the
most likely
time to buy things is when nobody else
will answer their phones. You know,
everybody else talks about their
wonderful trading departments and
everything. Just try them out sometime
when uh
markets are collapsing, they don't
answer the phones.
And and if they do, the the bids are
subject and the offers are subject and
the spread is wide and then and they'll
use the information they get from you
about what you want to do to go out and
kill you some other way. I mean, it it's
it's uh
it's really like going through a
slaughterhouse. I mean, you know you
don't feel like eating hot dogs for a
while.
>> [laughter]
>> I guess what I'm trying to get at is do
you see the circumstances building up
anywhere that could lead to a time like
that again? Is any any sort of panic in
the market?
>> Sure. Where do you see them?
>> Well, if you saw them as they wouldn't
happen. Okay. I mean, you've got all
kind
You don't worry about what what what
people are talking about can happen.
Uh it's it's something that comes out of
the blue.
But something will come out of the blue.
Yeah. I mean, a
uh
>> [laughter]
>> a nuclear bomb could come out of the
blue.
You know.
Well, let's knock on wood on that.
>> [laughter]
>> Well, well, I it doesn't do any good to
knock on wood. That's
It's It's that's the point. Yeah. It
you know, it was the Archduke
getting shot, you know, in the
1914 or something like that in World War
uh one and I
it it's just take everything in life.
And
it
if it
if something people are talking about
and thinking about, it's not going to
happen. Yeah. It but there are things
that can happen out of the blue. And
actually that's particularly true to use
that phraseology now because
the things that can come out of the sky
that
you know
we don't know what can happen tomorrow.
I mean, I don't like to talk that way to
the people, but
but it's you or anybody else. I mean,
cuz uh
I don't
whether it does you a lot of good to
worry about that. I don't think it does
you any good to to worry about it.
I think it's it's good to be cognizant
of it. But worrying about it is terrible
and I don't like to
I don't like to even cause that belief
with people. I don't like to go around
Yeah.
>> telling them the end is coming, the end
is coming or something like [laughter]
that.
A friend told me yesterday he's recently
started using the phrase, "I don't fret.
I don't worry." And that's probably a
good way to go about life. But let let's
talk about some of the issues that are
out there right now. Um
inflation is up. That's an issue. So,
how does Berkshire how does Berkshire
handle that with its businesses?
>> Well, we can't handle runaway inflation
except not to be there
in the way of it and
if you look at the number of countries
that run away inflation since World War
II in my lifetime.
It's very large. Yeah, and uh
and
uh
Once you
create that, it it becomes a different
world and
uh
You know, Germany obviously experienced
that after World War
I. But
but there are dozens and dozens of
countries that have experienced it. And
of course you have you have countries
that
have gone bankrupt like six or seven
times. I mean it's
>> [laughter]
>> it's
It's just amazing what people do. But uh
in financial markets.
What about the inflation that we're
dealing with right now, which is, you
know, not excessive. It's north of 3% at
this point, but we're not even back at
the levels we were during COVID.
>> 8 to 9%. So, what about just higher
energy prices, how that works through
the line, and how you handle it?
>> Well, it came close
before Volcker. I mean it was just it
was cash is trash, you know, and
people were losing faith
in the currency, and they felt they
could
borrow and 12% earn 6% on
on farming or something like that. And
they they had a huge farmers
in this state, Nebraska,
uh collapsed because
they bought beyond the earning power of
their paid interest rates beyond the
earning power just cuz they felt that
that
that uh the dollar was going to
disappear and the the land wouldn't
disappear and
it's it's
it's tragic
for many people and and uh
and
If you're the best doctor in town or the
best lawyer in town, you'll always make
money under any
choice.
Uh
The best the best TV personality. I mean
it's it's but
uh
What
Not having faith in the money
does to a country. It it turns it into
something else. Yeah. And I
You know, I've always hoped that you
know, the US never does it, but we are
not immune from that happening.
Uh
We have a lot of control
over whether rates may go up a half a
point or down a half a point, but but
we may have less control over whether
they go up 50 points.
>> [clears throat]
>> You've long been um
a supporter of Jay Powell's. Exactly.
>> He had his last FOMC meeting as chairman
uh just this last week. He did say that
he's going to be sticking around,
staying on the Fed, staying in that
position um for the foreseeable future
in part because of
uh the threats that he's faced. Um I'll
feel better when he's there.
Uh
when he's not. I mean it uh
it uh
No, I just felt better when Volcker was
there.
But you
it's
It kind of almost sunk the best in this
sort of thing. You know,
you read any old economics book from
1950 or
1970, it was
that uh
Paul Samuelson, who was a terrific guy,
and smart as hell.
Uh
He had the standard textbook for 25
years and
if you looked up, you know, uh uh uh
zero interest rates
and year after year after year,
it was a 900-page book and
there wasn't an entry for it. You know,
I mean it was the most important
economic development. I mean in terms of
the impact it would have and everything
during the lifetime of the students
reading it. But uh
uh
It's what you don't think of that
that does all the damage.
Let's talk a little bit about CEOs um
and some of the Berkshire holdings. You
mentioned Apple's uh Tim Cook and just
the phenomenal job you think he's done.
Incredible. Uh he's not the only one of
your major holding CEOs who stepped
down. James Quincey recently stepped
down from Coca-Cola, too. And we just
spoke with Vicki Hollub, who announced
that she is retiring and stepping down
from that position at Occidental. Um
part of what Greg's talked about is how
stable that portfolio is. And and these
holdings are companies that he knows and
managers that he
>> [music]
>> that he knows. There's going to be some
new managers in some of those major
holdings coming in. Is that a problem?
Well, it was certainly a problem at
Coca-Cola there for
a good many years when I was
around the company. I mean
sure, it's it's uh
And you have the most problems with with
with
a really good company because it'll
it'll it'll it'll continue.
I mean if you're
selling some product that people are
buying every day, you you can make the
wrong decision for a long time. Uh uh
But
that's one of the problems with
investing. That uh
uh
Tim Cook I I I felt was very very good
from the start. And and our
most of our managers
uh
are very good at the smaller problems.
Like
they can't anticipate the the over
looming problems. That's that's
that's uh my job or now Greg's job.
Do you feel good about those holdings
still? Have you met any of the new
managers?
I
I haven't met the old manager.
>> [laughter]
>> Of the new businesses of the new CEOs
that are coming in, Tim Cook's
replacement
>> know, and Luke at Coca-Cola.
>> met the people at the
at the labs that we Yeah. Yeah, I'm you
know, and obviously I met Vicki. We made
the deal.
And so
I I enjoy meeting the people and uh
uh
But you can make mistakes with people. I
mean look at the divorce rate.
You know, that's that's more important
than whether you got the right CEO or
anything else.
And and now you've got years of trial. I
mean back when I was young, you had you
had to make the decision.
You know, or you didn't have to make the
decision, but a good many people made
the decision when they were 20 or 21. To
get married. Yeah, they got married.
>> Yeah.
Now they they they spend five years,
they still make the same mistakes.
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> So, you think we're getting worse at our
judgment as we
>> Well, I don't know. And maybe the people
behave differently before the marriage
than after. Who knows exactly.
I would say that almost everybody feels
either the marriage is better or worse
than they anticipated a month after they
were married.
>> [laughter]
>> But I don't know which.
Um Warren, let's talk a little bit about
deep fakes because the deep fake Warren
that popped up early in this session was
pretty good. Um they had somebody
standing up, you know, Greg was joking
about it, but you know, the first the
first question went to a guy from Warren
up in the rafters who lives in Omaha. Um
you've been concerned about some of
these AI deep fakes and what that means
for the world.
>> Yeah, I would I would be
concerned if everybody was
Well, actually the worst thing would be
to have a
a a a uh
a really good imitator
of any president that came along. I mean
just imagine.
Well, yeah, we had that famous thing
before.
Way back in
in New Jersey where they
the Martians coming and everything like
that.
>> Oh, War of the Worlds with Orson Welles.
>> But what you what you can do
uh
Well, if you convince black people to
lend you money that they shouldn't you
shouldn't be borrowing it.
I mean
uh uh
it's
it's scary.
And it's it's particularly scary when
you
have nine countries or so with the
nuclear weapons and
and people working on in something even
more We haven't dealt with this.
We don't know what's going to happen.
Yeah.
Let's circle back to Berkshire and the
Berkshire of today.
I think I was speaking with you
yesterday or the day before and we were
talking a little bit about Greg Abel
and what a nice guy he is. And you said
>> terrific guy. You said something
interesting to me, though, um
about how you picked him and it wasn't
because he was a nice guy. Why did you
pick him?
Well, he's very very very smart about
businesses. Incidentally, he's getting
his Canadian I mean he's getting his
American citizenship here very soon and
he was
going over with me
all the things he had to learn about
and
I've actually spent
a little time in the past with
groups of individuals. Of course my wife
did did it till became an American
citizenship an American citizen.
And the things they have to learn about
the Constitution and all this and
they're usually so proud
when they become American citizens. And
I think I
I think I detected in Greg even. I mean
you know, there's
the successful he's been and everything
else. I mean
he is
it means something to him to become an
American citizen. And
uh
you know, and
he's a civil this
his young son, you know, and the son
knows more about some of the answers to
the questions, you know, that he may get
asked or something about becoming a
citizen. It's it's really interesting.
And
where else does that happen in the
world? I mean where people
you know, that that America's special.
And and uh
it's it's a miracle
uh what America's accomplished. I mean,
it's just an absolute miracle.
And
yet
the miracle the division of the
of of the output and everything is about
as inequitable as it you could come up
with, while at the same time
it's got these
great attractions. There is some secret
sauce.
I've never been able to define it
precisely, but uh
uh
when you run a country for 200 and some
years and people want to come here every
year, I mean
there's there's be something about it.
And when Greg Abel is very you know, is
looking forward
to becoming an American citizen
that means something to him.
And
you can't buy that any place. They're
packaging or you know,
won't work for a Madison Avenue approach
approach, you know,
being American or something like that.
But that that feeling just goes up in my
95 years. I've
I've seen it you know, time after time.
So
I felt I felt good when I
Greg just volunteered that in the last
day or two to me that he was
he's up there for his final exams here
pretty soon becoming a citizen.
>> I didn't realize he wasn't a dual
citizen already. I knew he was Canadian,
but I thought he had dual citizenship.
>> have a full whatever the complete
citizenship requirement is. And and you
can say why does he care? I mean, he's
gotten along fine with others here and
everything. He still wants to be a
citizen. Yeah.
250 years we're celebrating our 250th
anniversary.
Um
you pointed out that you've been around
for 95 of them. Do you think we have the
special sauce that that will continue in
this country or what do we need to do to
preserve that and make sure that it does
continue? We've got a special sauce.
There's
that's a secret sauce.
It's such a good secret that I don't
know what exactly
it is. But I do know this that that
anybody that has
a choice
would choose to be in born in America. I
mean, you know, you can pick some very
small little countries that are very
happy that they're but
this is is there any other country that
everybody's
couple hundred years has wanted to
emigrate to? I mean, it
it uh
and it attracted some terrible people,
you know, too, but
but uh
it worked.
And they had the mafias from the
different groups. I'm not not just the
Italian mafia, but all I mean, it it
wasn't that they were all we had some
system for picking out the the wonderful
people from some other countries.
But
it has
it has worked, but it's worked
the extremes to which it works.
Uh
don't seem to belong
to that kind of a society. I mean, if
you were drawing up
dreams for the ideal society
and you would have this kind of
GDP per capita and everything
you wouldn't design
the
you wouldn't design the inheritances
laws. You wouldn't I mean, you'd just do
all kinds of things differently, but
somehow it's worked.
But that doesn't mean that
uh
we can't do better. I mean,
at all.
You know, Warren, there are thousands of
people, shareholders and partners of
yours for decades in some cases, who are
sitting out in this arena right now. And
I just wonder if there's a message you'd
like to give to them. Um
those who've been following you for
years and who've been partners of yours
for years.
The number one rule of government is
just
that that that giving the golden rule.
Do unto others as you
I'm not a religious guy, but I mean
nobody's said it any better than than
than in a couple thousand years than
that. Which may be why it's lasted that
to a certain degree, too. I mean, that
uh
you know
more people are reading a 2,000-year-old
book about how to behave
than uh
anything that anybody's coming up with
lately. Uh
uh
Now, it's got a lot of
pretty the Old Testament's got different
kinds of stories to some extent. But
uh
if the whole world lived
by the golden rule, it would
be
such a more wonderful society. Do unto
others as you'd have them do unto you.
>> Yeah. And that's true for everything
from
parenthood
to being a boss to being all I mean,
just everything in life.
And it doesn't cost you anything. In
fact, it it it
it's reflected in better behavior toward
you. So I mean, it's a very selfish sort
of thing in a
in one sense.
But I've never seen anybody
that's unhappy that behaves that way.
They uh
uh and I've seen a lot of people
in a lot of different kinds of
situations.
Warren, I want to thank you for taking
this time to sit down with us today.
Warren Buffett the chairman of Berkshire
Hathaway. Uh Greg Abel is going to be
taking the stage in just a moment and
you will see more from him in just a
moment.